كان المستشفى الاندونيسي اول ضحايا العتمه
لكنه لم يكن الاخير الذي يستقبل جرح مجزره
دون كهرباء او قدره على علاج من وصل او
اغاثه من سيصل او قد يصل فلم يعد من شيء
من صنع البشر يعين اهل قطاع غزه نهار كل
شيء من حولهم الا عزيمتهم تعلن وزاره
الصحه انهيار المنظومه الصحيه تماما القصف
الاسرائيلي الذي لا يتوقف ولا يستثني
مشافي ونفاد الوقود واحكام الحصار واختفاء
الادويه والمعدات افضت لهذا الانهيار في
القطاع
الصحي انهيار كان محتوما وفق تحذيرات
متكرره من وزاره الصحه والاطقم الطبيه دون
ان يابه المجتمع الدولي كما تقول وزاره
الصحه في
غزه تعمل في قطاع غزه 5 مستشفى توقف منها
حتى لحظه اعداد هذا التقرير 15 مستش بشكل
كلي و 32 مركزا صحيا والخشيه قائمه من
توقف المزيد بمرور الساعات نظريا يفترض ان
تعتني العشرون المتبقيه باكثر من 15 الف
جريح والرقم مرشح للارتفاع في كل دقيقه مع
كل غاره اسرائيليه والغارات لا تتوقف
لتتحول المستشفيات المتبقيه الى مكان
يستقبل الام الفلسطينيين مع قدره محدوده
داوات الجرحى مهما كانت اصاباتهم طفيفه او
حرجه ضرب العصب الاساسي المنقذ لحياه
المصابين اذا ومعه استهدفت ايضا القدره
على التعامل مع ما يسجله اطباء من اصابات
غير اعتياديه بحروق تغطي في بعض الاحيان
80% من اجسام المصابين والشهداء لوجود
حروق شديده شديده للغايه تصهر معها اطراف
هؤلاء الجرح
والمصابين منظمه العفو الدوليه قالت في
تقرير لها في ال من اكتوبر الحالي ان
مختبر ادله الازمات في المنظمه جمع ادله
توثق استخدام اسرائيل قذائف الفوسفور
الابيض في قصفها مناطق مكتظه في قطاع غزه
بعدها ظهرت اصابات في غزه يقول اطباء انهم
لم يعهدها من قبل هناك شواهد ومؤشرات اخرى
متمثله فيما رصدته طواقم الطب
الشرعي من علامات على اجساد وجثامين
الشهداء وكذلك الجرحى سواء بنسب الحروق
العاليه واذابه جلود الشهداء
والجرحى وتحت وطاه المجازر والقصف وفشل
المنظومه
الصحيه يعيش ابناء غزه وسط ثنائيه تهدد كل
ملامح الحياه في
القطاع